SPEAKER: Making
money with an app
is a goal pursued
by many developers.
To help Android developers, we
launched the In-App Billing API
v3 in 2013, to make it
easier for developers
to offer products and
subscription within their apps.
And now, we are
taking a new step
to simplify billing further with
the new Play Billing Library.
This library includes several
convenience classes, as well as
a wrapper for the
billing service,
allowing you to focus on
implementing the logic
specific to your app.
In-app billing relies
on the Google Play Store
app, which handles the
communication between your app
and Google's billing service.
To use in-app billing
features, your app
must first request the
com.android.vending billing
permission in your
Android manifest XML file.
To use the library, add
the following dependency
in your [INAUDIBLE] file.
But attention-- check on
the Play Billing Library
page for the latest
version number
to add the correct
dependency in your app.
After you're set up, you
are good to go and start
using the Play Billing Library.
To start sending
billing requests,
you must establish a
connection to the service
on Google Play using
the following steps.
First, create a
BillingClient instance
using the Builder class, passing
the [INAUDIBLE] at Context,
and set a reference
to an instance
of PurchasesUpdatedListener.
You can implement this
interface in your activity.
When the user finishes
a purchase process,
Google Play calls the
onPurchasesUpdated method
on the listener that implements
the PurchasesUpdatedListener
interface, where you should
handle the transaction result.
Second, establish a connection
to the in-app billing service
on Google Play.
The setup process
is asynchronous,
and you must implement a
BillingClientStateListener
to receive a callback once
the setup is completed.
Overwrite the onBillingServices
connected callback method
and implement your
own retry policy
to handle lost connections
with in-app billing service,
in the case the client
loses connection.
For example, the Play
Billing Library client
may lose connection if
the Play Store Service
is updating in the background.
You can check the full sample
code in our documentation.
With your app connected
to Google Play,
you can state sending
requests for in-app products.
Let's start by listing
the products available
for purchase, executing
the asynchronous method,
querySkuDetailsAsync.
To make a request using
querySkuDetailsAsync,
you have to specify
the purchase type--
in this case, SkuType.INAPP--
and a list of
product ID strings,
where each record is a product
ID for a purchasable item.
These product IDs
were defined by you
when you created the product
list on the Google Play
Console.
For more information about
creating a product list,
see Administering
In-App Billing.
You must also
specify a listener,
which implements the
SkuDetailsResponseListener
interface that overwrites the
onSkuDetailsResponse method
to handle the method result.
Call the ResponseCode
method on the
SkuDetailsResult object
to check for the response code.
The response code should
be BillingResponse.OK
if the request
finishes successfully.
To view all the
possible response
codes from Google Play, see
Play Billing Library Reference.
To retrieve the list
of SkuDetails objects,
call the
getSkuDetailsList method
from the
SkuDetailsResult. You can
call a variety of methods
on SkuDetails objects
to view relevant
information about each item,
such as its price
or description.
Of course, being able
to just list products
doesn't lead to profit.
To start a purchase
request from your app,
call the
launchBillingFlow method
on the Play Billing Library
client from the UI thread.
Pass a reference to
the billingFlowParams
object that contains the
relevant data to complete
the purchase, such
as the product
ID of an item and
the purchase type.
In this case, SkuType.INAPP.
To get an instance of
Billing Flow Params,
use the Billing Flow
Params Builder class.
Calling the
launchBillingFlow method
displays a Google Pay
UI purchase screen.
Google Play provides
an interface for users
to enter their payment method.
As mentioned earlier, when
the user finishes a process,
Google Play calls the
onPurchasesUpdated method
on the listener that implements
the PurchasesUpdatedListener
interface.
In this method, each purchase
will be an item on a list,
as you can see here.
When you receive the purchase
response from Google Play,
perform a secure validation
in your own account.
Don't trust the client, since an
Android app could be decompiled
and your security checks
replaced with stubs.
To retrieve the history
of user purchase,
call the queryPurchases method
on the Play Billing Library
client.
The Google Play service
returns the purchase
made by the user
account associated
with the app installed.
If the request is successful,
the Play Billing Library
stores the query result in a
list of purchasable objects.
To retrieve the list, call
the getPurchasesList method
on the PurchaseResult object.
The Purchase object has methods
to view relevant information
about the item, such as
the purchase date or time.
Google Play prevents the user
from owning more than one copy
of an item by product ID.
The item must be consumed before
it can be purchased again.
Your app controls how
items are consumed.
To consume items, you
first implement an instance
of ConsumeResponseListener to
handle the consumption result.
Then you call the consumeAsync
method on the Play Billing
Library client, passing the
identifying purchaseToken
string value.
If the response code
in onConsumeFinished
from your
ConsumeResponseListener
is billing OK, it's time to
call a method that implements
the logic in your app to
update the player's inventory
or release credits to be used.
Another great feature
covered by Play Billing API
is subscriptions.
But before launching the
billing flow for subscriptions,
call the
isFeatureSupported method
on the Play Billing
Library client
to check that the device
supports subscriptions
with the type as
featureType.SUBSCRIPTIONS.
Purchasing or renewing
a subscription
is similar to launching the
purchase flow for a product.
You just set the product type
to SkuType.SUBS and the product
ID of the subscription before
you call launchBillingFlow.
If the user is changing
a subscription option,
you must also pass
the product IDs
for the subscription
items you are replacing
in the BillingFlowParams object
using the addOldSku method.
You can create an instance
of BillingFlowParams
using the BillingFlowParams
Builder class.
Just as in purchase,
Google Play returns
the result of the
operation using
the onPurchasesUpdated callback.
This library is designed and
maintained by our engineers,
and we make plans to keep it up
to date with the latest In-App
Billing API and Google Play app.
If you want to see details of
how to use the Play Billing
Library, including support for
Android Wear and Android TV,
check the refreshed version
of the Trivial Drive sample.
We look forward to
hearing your feedback
about this new library.
Thanks for watching.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]